bien bonjour bonjour jean baptiste
bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous alors
aujourd'hui on va voir une très grande
variantes de sicilienne dans un mode
accéléré à lokossa victimes il s'agit de
la sicilienne dragon
cette fameuse cécilienne réputé pour
pour ses qualités offensives
lorsqu'elle est joué je dirais entre
guillemets normalement ici une petite
différence puisqu'on va regarder le
dragon accéléré alors le dragon accéléré
c'est un jeu qui ressemble beaucoup aux
dragons normal mais on va voir ça quand
même pas mal de petites nuances qu'il
faut maîtriser
on va voir aujourd'hui effectivement
dragon accéléré avec nuance puisque
c'est sang et or il ya parce qu'on peut
le jouer avec et aux sang et or on va en
parler il sera plus clair quand on verra
les coups ça sera plus qu'à contrôler un
coup d'oeil on va se baser sur des
spécialistes de cette ouverture puisque
on va se baser sur une partie anand
tibia coffre de grands spécialistes
mondiaux de cette ouverture alors on y
va
alors si jacob faut effectivement été un
très grand spécialiste nous avons
accéléré alors en maîtres russes
malakoff e41 c5 sicilienne classique
karl olive 3 qui réalise les filles
cavaliers c6 des quatre s'éprend des
cats une sixième classique car il prend
des 4 et là tout de suite
j-6 tout de suite j'ai 6 ouais c'est là
où celle ci lui c'est là où s'est
accélérée effectivement nord c'est aussi
à ce moment là que les blancs on saute
un carrefour en fait ils ont le choix
entre soit se développer normalement on
joue interreliés ces trois comme ci
comme ça c'est rien aux normales koala
il de la pièce tout à fait logiquement
soit il joue ses 4 je sais qu'à donc ça
c'est la variante avec et tous et pas
celle qu'on va voir aujourd'hui voilà ce
qu'on appelle même
une mare au xi qui porte le nom de
l'étau oui parce que les taux demeurent
1,6 et ses fameux pioncer au 4 rue de la
mare aux xi avec ses 4 pour empêcher de
jouer le coup des cinq classiques et oh
mais c'est parce qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est la vente classique de temps
accéléré avec câble et c3 a calé ses
trois donc faux g7 alors on va voir flou
g7 donc ça c'est l'idée on se développe
très vite voyez tout de suite déjà il ya
une menace sur le travail des quatre
évidemment prendre le cavaly sait si ce
serait une faute
alors c'est pas conseillé c'est toute
façon un coup stéphane qu'il faut
presque jamais faire dans la défense
sicilienne
pourquoi parce que d'autres cavaliers
des quatre est très bien placé au centre
et puis aussi et surtout parce qu'on
consolide la domination central des
noirs voilà qui jouent comme tu le fais
b processus et qui vont pouvoir jouer
facilement leurs pions au centre ensuite
avec 5 et des cinq cas tu nous fais de
belles flèches qui montre bien que les
noirs n'ont aucune difficulté ensuite
vous reprendre le centre donc c'est un
coup sauf justification vraiment
sérieuse qui ne faut jamais fait à quel
point ce lundi
donc le coût normal c'est de jouer donc
voilà on maintient le cavalier au centre
jour feu trois mois donc il faut
protéger ce cavalier nous battre en
retraite ce serait déjà une victoire
pour les noirs et des cas très bien
placé il conserver au centre kalyev 6
pour les noirs classiques alors annoncé
que dans la dragon habituel on les noirs
ont pris peine de jouer le coup des 6 et
là ils n'ont pas fait ils essaient de
alors c'est ça en fait
la petite nuance dont je parlais au
début de notre leçon qui n'est pas
facile à expliquer comme ça si on voit
pas des coups mais en fait qu'elle est
l'inconvénient de la dragon normal
l'inconvénient c'est que les blancs
peuvent développer une taxe très rapide
et très est très féroce sur le petit
rock avec dame d2 et fois çi ces grands
rock
alors on va montrer un dam des deux fois
6 et il rend rock voilà alors que dans
cette variante est bien et blanc peuvent
être tentés de jouer peut-être plus
tranquillement et coup comme fou aux
deux parce que sinon je vous donne des
deux tout de suite qu'est ce qui va se
passer
cavaliers 82 voilà c'est si on joue la
dame en d2 si on joue la dame en d2
alors on peut pas logique a tout de
suite non non c'est si on joue là
d'amendé e d'amendé de gauche doit
demander eux il y aura cavaliers g4 qui
oblige une carte et ça le problème
attac nous trois qui s'y vend ashes peu
étant prises aussi catastrophe puisqu'on
on perd le foot recasement quatre mois
que doit rester là ne pas bouger parce
qu'ils sont ils accueillent des cadres
qui tombe donc c'est pour ça que les
blancs peuvent être tentés jeunes bien
tenté de jouer fouet 2 qui est beaucoup
d'enjeux dont je parlais tout à l'heure
on n'est plus du tout dans l'attaqué
voilà on n'est plus du tout dans dans la
taille dans la variante de dragon normal
le foot doit être en c4 nature et même
les blancs peuvent être tentés après
deux coups de faciliter petit rock et
alors là le dragon commence à être une
variante non seulement beau mais en plus
sans danger puisque avec le petit rock
on peut pas attaquer comme dans le ragot
normal avec le rock c'est pour ça que
des fois des noirs choisi cette sorte de
coup dragon accéléré pour inciter les
blancs sur un jeu trop mou à choisir une
variante plus paisible bien sûr alors là
à noter aussi que des coûts
de type f3 tout de suite qu'ils sont
classiques dans le dragon normal aussi
ils sont pas bons parce que ici on peut
jouer f3 avait l'idée dam des deux jeux
vous rendre dans la même variante que le
dragon je fais grand roque
ouais mais là ça marche pas bien en fait
bon c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
possible quand même un etc tu pensais à
un coût qui est embêtant c'est ça qui
est le coût va jeu non non non je
pensais à des coups comme dessein ou
d'un v6 d'amsterdam b6 qui sont
classiques quoi par exemple d'un v6 oui
avec des menaces
enfin des fins des possibilités d'un v6
tout de suite ça doit pas être très bon
ce cavalier f5 quand même que la dame
attaque le fou attaque assez jamais
clair à ce qu'être adam prend b2
cavaliers pranger s'être le roi vient la
fuite du cassieu plus sortir avec des
pièces bien sûr voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on vous conseille nous en tout cas de
jouer des coups plus sûr plus sûr et qui
ont toutes façons leur place dans les
variantes de dragon qui par exemple
beaucoup poussé quatre pouces et quatre
qui est logique on garde un oeil ici
avec la dame toujours sur le cavalier m6
pour qu'ils passent puisse pas venir en
g4 embêter le fou en jour sous ces
quatre on empêche aussi des ventes avec
des scènes qui sont aussi possibles dans
cette variante là c'est aussi l'idée on
joue pas des six parce que peut-être en
se ménageant la possibilité jouer des
cinq champs elysées donc la foux ses
cartons garde l'exil après puis on reste
aussi on colle à la voir en dragon
normal alors c'est à dire qu'on va pas
se faire on va pas se faire amener sur
un sur un chemin où les noirs pour avoir
un bon dragon
on respecte les coûts habituels dragon
et moi aussi d'ailleurs nora dans
d'autres le sont sûrement joué petit
rock petit rock voilà
attention maintenant petit rock la green
earth existe c'est à dire que la menace
des noirs maintenant ses cavaliers prend
1,4 alors attends sur la menace
maintenant ses cavaliers prendre quatre
alors on va montrer sur un genou faible
par exemple de dire 'ok je passe dans
sur petit à petit rock ont vertement 4
et sur caméléon 2004 et bien des cinq
des 5 avec fourchette donc on récupère
la pièce et par cette petite astuce
tactique et bien des noirs ont réussi à
échanger le pion des contres le pion le
pion aux finalement et il restera plus
qu'un pion central c'est le pion à eux
voilà donc l'énorme avantage au centre
et puis un très beau fouiller cet qui a
donc cessé de super finale voilà donc le
bien ou le vent ou du dragon le fameux
donc tout est justifié un ici c'est la
raison pour laquelle son petit rock on
joue pas petit road soi même tout petit
rock on enlève le foot cette case
malheureuse qui est devenu malheureuse
un petit rock et on retire le four en b3
bien sûr beaucoup four b3 voilà donc au
four b3 on garde le fou ce très bonne
diagonale et puis on se prend pas qu'ils
avaient pris 1,4 voilà donc pour
l'instant tranquille donc là les noirs
jouent des 6 es sérieux là on rentre
dans la variante presque oui presque
s'est pas revu ça ressemble vraiment un
dragon
nan mal alors et
la ici la menace après des six ses fans
c'est de jouer encore une fois cavalier
g4 parce que le maintenant le fou j'ai
ces huit contrôlent la quasi cas donc
avalé g4 est dans l'air du temps
toujours pareil c'est déstabiliser ce
que ce fou oui le même sur dam des deux
pourra pas venir insiste puisque lequel
j'ai quatre contrôles aussi dans la case
ça posait un gros problème au fouet 3
qui encore une fois est obligé de rester
cette case là pour protéger le cavalier
oui parce que ce cahier des quatre aussi
est en prise donc se fout de 3 est
fondamental donc voilà les idées donc le
coup logique qui suivent le coup et
trois qui classique de la vente d'art y
allait du coup il y avait 3 et avait h3
il ya aussi évidemment le coup h3 qui
permet h3c plus tôt alors là si on leur
compte on enlève les possibilités
d'attaqués
voilà on sort un peu de cette ligne
d'attac habituel que la variante dragon
normal on veut jouer h3 mais avec une
autre idée c'est que le bio est en fait
on le destine à être poussée jusqu en f4
pour attaquer d'une autre façon on veut
jouer f4 voilà on peut continuer la
variante d'ailleurs par exemple tout
comme damas 5 voilà elle est bien
attention menace cavaliers prend 4 parce
que lecavalier cloud est allé prendre un
cas puisque le cavaly c3 ici plus par
l'adam donc le coup petit rock devient
logique voilà fou 17-17 développement et
madaef quatre cavaliers prend des cas de
fou 40 des cas mais quand ces six fours
et 6e vous se recycle sur la db9 après
sur le pion à eux extrêmement classique
aussi on est obligé de le protéger avec
l'homme de 3,3 et par exemple tour à des
huit avec la menace ses fans eux 5 avec
eux cinq pour déstabiliser le fou des
quatre déjà la dame ici on voit bien que
la dame contrôler la case de cinq ans
crée un vis-à-vis en fait désagréable
tour dames
il ya par ici et je veux bien signalé
aussi c'est que le coup et cinq dans le
dragon se joue aussi
pour des raisons très précises c'est à
dire qu'on ne joue jamais le pion à eux
en hausse 5,6 à bloc le fou g7 et que
l'on ne pourra jamais bougé par exemple
sur cinq
s'il a pu en prendre cinq pions prendre
5 et que ça d'attaqué rien alors le fou
j'ai cette actu le statut le fuji caezar
en terre complètement le fou gsm alors
qu'ici e 5.325 n'est pas possible parce
qu'ils soient plus on prend 2,5
la tour exerce un cloud assure le fou
des quatre cellules et voilà et le pion
pour reprendre le fou ou suivant
donc voilà le monde là c'est un jeu je
dirais plutôt équilibré on peut
reconstituer par exemple par tour a eu
un qui est une possibilité sur cinq on
retire simplement le fou en 3 et chacun
a ses arguments
voilà c'est une partie qui est plutôt
équilibré jal et noir vont sans doute
prendre
ils doivent prendre la grande récré
hâtivement comme on le disait il y aura
un échange donc voilà donc alors sinon
on a joué trois pilotes coup oui là pour
finir avec h3 quand même une petite
petite filouterie que je voudrais vous
montrez d'accord donc dans la variante
avec h3c cavaliers à cinq cavaliers qui
s'il se rallie à saint d'accord sur un
gel sera donc on a joué le coup h3 et là
au lieu de jouer le coup d'un malien qui
joue beaucoup cavalli à 5
voilà c'est une très bonne variante
précisément dans ce genre de dans ce
genre de suite
il faut en fait l'essuie tout y aura a
priori pas grand roque
donc on sait que venir prendre comme ça
le fou en b3 quand on a grand roque avec
les blancs on sait que c'est pas connu
fischer en a même fait une théorie que
c'est pas bon pense connu c'est pas bon
sur calais prend b3 yacé prendre des
trois oui on fait grand roque et roye b
1 et on dit que cette position n'est pas
attaquable la formation des pions n'est
pas attaquable
voilà donc c'est un coup qu'on se
garderait bien de faire si les blancs
d'essayer de faire grand roque
mais là ils ont un peu traîné avec h3 il
montre en tout cas qui ne veulent pas
jouer avec f3 et g4 la fameuse attaque à
la baïonnette contre le fils keto donc
on va prendre ce fonds ensuite on va se
développer avec b6 est fou bessette
petit rock voilà b6 b6 voilà ensuite
donc à tout moment on peut prendre ce
four à tout moment dans son état il sort
sa c4
après thor séville on peut se garder en
réserve le coup
cavalier c4 après le soutien de la tour
effectivement fou bessette et on a joué
l idée quand même c'est passionel flambé
cette ensuite exception sera protégé 1,4
c'est prendre en d5 jouer eux 5 et
jouets des 5
voilà une bonne suite parce que il n'y a
plus assez de contrôles sur la caisse
des cinq donc le centre noir peut
exploser le pirée et ça va donner un
avantage donc vous conseille pas le coup
h3 et comme tout à l'heure on vous
conseille de coller à la variante
d'attac du dragon habituel avec f3 il
faut coller mais dans le bon nombre de
coups faut pas jouer d'amd neutre ou
tours font bien jouer cet ordre de coûts
dans cet ordre là voyez d'ailleurs aussi
vous apprêtez à jouer ça avec les blancs
on vous conseille de vous repassez cette
leçon et de bien comprendre l'ordre de
coûts en essayant peut-être de trouver
vous même quelques où vous allez jouer a
dit qu'il pose
on cherche on vérifie qu'il pose on
cherche on vérifie et comme ça on se
trompe j'avais dans l'ordre de goût
parce que ce serait dommage de faire un
apprentissage douloureux pour une prune
de vos parties donc fou d'essai de la
part des noirs
la dame des deux là on peut dire qu'on
est rentré dans l'avion tu-154 a fait un
saut même pas alors l'idée on va le
rappeler ces tours civic grand roque
voilà et l'idée pour les blancs c'est
c'est de jouer on peut jouer alors s'il
n'a rejoué la scène comme tu l'as dit
c'est pas une alors c'est pas très grave
alors oui c'est l'idée de venir en ces
cas là c'est pour venir danser 4
effectivement ça c'est la grande
variantes mais en fait génère d'ailleurs
on passe par le simple parce qu'on veut
museler ce four b3 sans pour autant le
prendre pour les raisons que l'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure et éventuellement
aussi s'attaquer aux fous ou trois pour
laisser le fou g700 sans homologues en
fait il serait très très puissant s'il
était le damné défaut noir sur cet
échiquier donc cavalier prend des quatre
est une autre possibilité
dans ce cas d'impossibilité alors fou
prend des cas donc là qui enlève la
halle attaque directe mais qui là les
blancs ouais c'est une position qui est
assez intéressante effectivement ils ont
des perspectives d' attaque quand même
assez forte avec le pion à ce qui est
prêt à partir on n'a pas dit mais
effectivement c'est très important de
faire grand roque puisqu'on a besoin de
la tour âge pour attaquer le long de cet
ouvrage pour ouvrir la colonne pour
avoir des voies de communication sur le
petit rock noir
c'est pour ça que les mois devront pris
tout de suite en d4 pour pouvoir courir
après pour attaquer les premiers en fait
avec des cinq 5 mois l'abandon mais
voilà ces classiques aussi de la vente
du dragon évidemment le groupe b 5 on
est protégé par trou 17 ans jouent et b4
avec la tour c'est vide qui tape sur le
mois le fonds qui commence à se
réveiller aussi potentiellement petite
idée aussi si c'est le coincer le fou au
b 3e à 5 à 4 c'est donc aussi ce four b3
donc à 5 à 4 avec le coin s'agit ici du
fond et c'est pour ça que les blancs
train dé prendre des mesures urgentes et
qui joue cavalier des cinq donc câbles
et des 5 alors ça c'est classique aussi
du dragon on veut éliminer ce que
j'essaie donc le fou des cas très bien
placé pour sa part demanderont fait
sûrement mais si ce cavalier sur une
case que l'on dit d'avant-postes c'est
pas une case forte une case forte c'est
une case sur laquelle on peut mettre une
pièce sans être chassé par un pion un
avant poste c'est une case sur laquelle
on peut mettre une pièce mais en fait
tout ce qui va arriver à cette pièce
et ben oui c'est bien on les change
auquel cas on peut reprendre du plomb et
ça ouvre une colonne sur un pion à
regret le bureau de 7 soit il se passe
rien cavalier bien placé soit on le
chasse avec le 7e 6 et dans ces cas là
c'est dramatique pour le plan ii des six
qui tombe immédiatement
bien sûr voilà donc c'est une case
d'avant-postes c'est pas aussi fort
comme son nom l indique une case forte
mais c'est une case qui est très
intéressante et de devecser votre plan
de jeu sur ce genre de cas lorsque vous
en possédez une donc la variante
classique ici voilà il faut prendre
quand même parce qu'il ya une pression
qui est tellement forte sur le cavalier
f6 qu on est obligé de s'en débarrasser
fu pranger cercle on est content parce
qu'on a éliminé le grand bain de foule
dangereux voilà après le roi prend g7 et
a bien sûr on prend du dupiot pions non
pas du fou dont van damme mais du pion
quid du fou mais ce fait une erreur il
perd du temps en fait briller puisque
toujours pas tirés d'affaires parce
qu'après à 5 pour me lasserai e6 faux
bouge à 4000 suivant faire mal fou donc
c'est pas une très bonne option
alors là on joue ce avec une petite
pointe de regret c'est que ce four b3
finalement il a un pion qui le gêne
oui
mais je dirais que c'est passager il
faut quand même il va pouvoir se
recycler plus tard avec ses trois fils
et 2 et puis on peut pas tout avoir
moi je propose qu'on regarde aussi les
droits quand même bien sûr on voit que
les pièces noires sont complètement
coupés de la défense du roi champions il
joue quand même un rôle important parce
que les pièces ne peuvent pas regagner
la de la défense pourra jouer tour ses 5
pour 1 par là par exemple déjà on peut
pas faire ça
voilà on a joué aussi s'annonce
expression trop froid nature partout et
les blancs vont pouvoir quand même lancé
une attaque avec h41 kaddache scène
qu'on peut jouer g4 sacrifier un pion
avec une grosse attaque donc attention
il ya quand même du venait dans cette
position il manque des pièces de défense
voilà c'est une étape de rock poser ou
les noirs sont un petit peu sans défense
même si c'est les noirs pour un peu
d'avancé pour l'instant pour l'attack
parce que là ils vont jouer à 5 à 5
voilà donc là on est obligé quand même
de sauver d'autres fous moi je mens 3
mont joux à trois et non pas non pas à
ces trois puisque l'on donnerait des
coûts pour se faire battre
ça fait un peu cette colonne séoul à
tour est déjà bien placé donc là sur la
carte on peut jouer x 2 et on pourra
ensuite les lentilles ans plus tard il
faut via bien alors à voir si les noirs
jouent à 4 quand je vous fous à 2
ensuite on peut jouer ses trois pascal
res et c'est un mauvais la plaque à vent
glacial relation très très solide région
évidemment faudrait pas jouer ses trois
temps que la poussée b4 est possible
d'investissement pour un petit peu les
pièces en attaque tour h20 voyez que
finalement et bien réception 17 qui fait
c'est le pion le set qui est intéressant
ça ne m'empêchera pas peut-être de jouer
à chat à schalke sait pas où on va le
faire après tour et fait 8 on va jouer
g4 voilà on va affaiblir en fait
seulement avec les pions on préfère
mettre les tours au centre pour exercer
une pression sur sur le tueur de cette
voie là et on part facilement les
attaques les velléités des noirs c'est
par exemple sur b4 voilà on joue à
quatre à quatre et on peut déjà je pense
conclure cette variante du dragon
accélérée qui s'en est tout sans eto'o
qui nous a permis de rentrer dans une
variante de dragon je dirais assez
classique et bien on voit que les
chances d'attac des noirs sont
un peu tombé à l'eau alors que
les blancs ils ont encore que des bonnes
choses à faire ils sont un peu en retard
c'est vrai mais maintenant que l'ale
dame est complètement verrouillé et bien
ils ont des ce qu'il faut faire
attention ne servent à rien c'est
surtout ce qu'on a vu jean baptiste say
cet ordre de coûts qui permet de coller
à la vente précis ça c'est le plus
important
voilà si on rate ça les noirs vont
pouvoir jouer des dessins qui vont
pouvoir parfois joué des mêmes bêtises
des choses très attendu mais si on joue
dans cet endroit bien précis
il n'y a pas de problème particulier
bien les noirs ou un double pari enfin
qu'ils espèrent que les blancs et de
faire une grosse faute dans l'ordre de
coûts ou l'art avec prendre un avantage
ou alors que en changeant l'ordre de
coûts eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire enjoint
dragon accéléré non pas un dragon les
blancs
ne sache pas très bien comment le gérer
leurs ordres de coups et ne retombe pas
dans la grande ligne du dragon si ces
fois-là qui il faut le dire quand même
et la plus pénible
on n'a pas de tuer le dragon encore il
ya beaucoup de joueurs qu'ils jouent oui
et
on dit que dragon faut le tuer plusieurs
fois mais on sait comment on faisait
pour pour le battre en tout cas donc
effectivement les blancs doivent comme
ça se tenir à cette ligne du dragon
normal pour pouvoir bien jouer le dragon
accélérer certains pourront penser
peut-être que c'est l'évidence même je
sais comme moi je commence tout juste là
d'où cette variante là après avoir
compris qu'il fallait jouer comme ça
après 20 ans d'échec je jouais le dragon
accéléré différemment du dragon normal
et je comprenais pas pourquoi les noirs
contre moi n'avaient jamais de problème
sur dragon accéléré oui
donc on a dit quelque chose je pense de
très important bien sûr tout à fait
c'est tordu taux de 5,2 sont extrêmement
précis donc on vous invite à aller à
aller à les retenir la bien comprendre à
chaque fois pourquoi ou soupe ou avant
dans celui ci il faudra associer cette
leçon à la leçon sur le dragon déçu
après faudra regarder les grandes armes
du dragon puisqu'on va pouvoir retrouver
évidemment d'hellemmes en fonction de
comment les noix aussi réagissent 7,8
donc il faut être très très précis dans
ce type de variantes pour bien
verrouiller la partie voilà merci le
jean baptiste poux recettes
merci stéphane leçon merci au revoir au
revoir